when it comes to handsome hunks in
Hollywood most of them share a single
name and that is Chris Chris Evans Chris
Pratt Chris Pine and Chris Hemsworth
that's what our show is about today
we're gonna determine a winner the best
Chris of the bunch
it's Captain America versus Captain Kirk
versus star-lord versus Thor yes they
all work out
whoo you kidding well you one sandwich
away from that here's how the show works
round number one box office round number
two tomato meter round number three best
franchises and we'll have a wild-card
round that even I don't know about as I
did not study my notes round one box
office what's incredible about Club
Chris is that all these lads have an
average box office draw well north of a
hundred million dollars per movie
they're so far north they're seeing
white walkers from the show beefing up
that numbers of course their various
franchise endeavors like the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Star Trek and
Jurassic Park so while Chris Pratt leads
all the fellas with 3.7 billion dollars
in total grosses is Chris Hemsworth who
eats out the best average movie take
with a hundred and eighty six point six
million dollars to Chris Pratt's just
trailing one hundred and eighty five
point two million dollars the bronze
medalist in both categories is Chris
Evans and Chris Pine brings up the very
chiseled rear with 2.2 billion dollars
overall and a healthy 124 million dollar
average per movie so Pine is obviously
at a disadvantage because he's not in
the MCU and domestically his highest
grossing Star Trek film the first JJ
Abrams reboot that also counts for Chris
Hemsworth so despite box office duds
like in the heart of the sea and black
hat I like both of those Chris Hemsworth
is the one that impresses me the most it
was a photo finished between him and the
Raptor trainer but I'm giving this round
to the son of Odin
round number two tomato meter okay so
our movies are making plenty of bread
that's a given but which Chris is
actually pumping out the most quality
content look I made a shrimp claw now
you might think that the MCU click has
the advantage but get this
none of the Marvel chrissa's have one of
those films as their highest rated on
Rotten Tomatoes Chris Evans has
snowpiercer
awesome train movie Chris Pratt has the
lego movie awesome is the trademark and
Chris Hemsworth has you guessed it Star
Trek starch he was in it for like nine
seconds bruce greenwood is quoted in the
movie is saying to Chris Pine your
father was the captain of the enterprise
for like three minutes or something your
father was Captain of a starship for 12
minutes so while Hemsworth has the best
tomato meter average of all the Chris's
let's take a look at Chris Pines resume
he has twin 97-percent with heller high
water and spider-man into the spider
birth not to mention he's had to make
choices that don't automatically pad his
stats he doesn't get the MCU benefit he
doesn't have an infinity war or a
Ragnarok or a Guardians and as such he
stars in four of the top ten tomato
meter films of all the Chris's that are
not based on comic books or franchises
hell or high water stretch unstoppable
and z for Zachariah
well that's named Chris Pratt puts up
the best fight here as he was also a
part of three Best Picture nominees
Moneyball zero dark thirty and her but
he was in the center of any of them
thanks so Chris Pratt thanks for helping
us cap bin Laden but this round goes to
Jimmy Tiberius Kirk Chris Pine perfect
round number three best franchises well
okay that's enough non franchise talk
look I love range when it comes to an
actor and all these boys have it but can
you extend that acting range into
multiple billion-dollar franchises like
if Stan Lee or dinosaurs want you in
their movies can you deliver the goods
Chris Hemsworth can if it's in the MCU
we all love Thor but we love him more
when he's sharing screen time with Hulk
so wait chris hemsworth Chris Evans he
has also had a trilogy of Captain
America films plus he injected some life
into those Fantastic Four flicks it's
clobberin time
I'm sure the cast and crew of those
movies thought you know someday we're
gonna be used as a tiebreaker and Rotten
Tomatoes they dream achieve Fantastic
Four Chris Pine is carrying the water
for the Star Trek franchise but its
future is in limbo what - this round is
gonna be all about Chris Pratt yes we
love him to Star War he's great as the
Raptor trainer in the Triassic Park
movies and he puts together one hell of
a Lego set it always seems like Chris
Pratt is the name who surfaces for any
new rebooted franchise attempt cowboy
ninja Viking give me Pratt Indiana Jones
somebody page Chris James Bond should
probably call it yourself Oh know what
you'll see and now we come to the
wild-card round who saves the day the
most now I'll be honest with you all I
wanted this round to be all about awards
who's one of those two Kennedy Awards
none of them who's been nominated for
the most Academy Award again none of
them who's won the most team Choice
Awards well actually they've all wanted
Thank You Nickelodeon you're the one
channel left that isn't afraid to slime
it stars we're safe
Pratt Hemsworth and pine all played
heroes that saved the day Pratt saves
humans raccoons and ancient species Thor
saved his people from the destruction of
their home planet Asgard and Kirk saves
the crew and sometimes the fate of the
entire solar systems and then obviously
Captain America he's just a roided-up
runt from Brooklyn who saves all of us
so we're tired so now we go to the
real-life heroes Chris Pratt played one
of the soldiers of God Osama
Chris Pine played a brave sea captain in
finest hours and Chris Hemsworth starred
as one of the horse soldiers and 12
strong these are all good pictures but
in real real reality life Chris Evans
did save the day for Regina King at the
Oscars remember she's going to accept
the reward and the dress is making it
cumbersome who lends a hand the nice guy
who's always instagramming about his
cute puppy Chris Evans Evans is gonna
get the win here because he saves a day
a time and he doesn't have that brain
fart moment like Thor Kirk or star war
did so for me the overall win is gonna
go - I'm gonna go Chris Hemsworth big
mistake what the man I was gonna go
Pratt because he can do everything
action drama comedy but I'm still upset
about the Thanos thing we had him but
hey I look at the Chris's like they're
my children I love them all equally so
now it's your turn vote in the comments
section right now we're gonna be
checking the comments to see which Chris
takes the belt whoever it is I'm sure
that belts is size 32 waist the gold
standard someday Marc someday we'll have
the results in a future episode and
until then I'm Marc Ellison I also
frequently Instagram my dog did I share
with my ex-girlfriend you hear that
Chris Evans you want to be friends
follow back
you